remember been saying over ever again
it's a ratio like it's a ratio between
these two things and up and rabies and
up and rabies can we work out just
quickly come back to this question can
you work out for me what is the actual
lock like I'm now now I'm curious
I think air what was before but now I
would like the actual number can someone
tell it to you just okay now the reason
why I draw this out now is because I
know what the arc length is now 18.3%
minutes and I know what the radius is
seven centimeters so if I were
interested in the size of this angle in
radians then in this particular example
I would say eighteen point three
centimeters about seven centimeters now
this has been or could we usually don't
give a rip about units all that much
because we left kind of like I know what
you need to do it's not made as a combo
like that but if I write the angle in
this way the units are kind of a big
deal because do you notice just like all
of units if you multiply by a unit as
I'm doing on the nyrians and you divide
by a unit as I'm doing on the
denominator right these units should
cancel should there not like that does
that make sense and they could be
kilometers in kilometers it's still
cancel or meters and meters still cancel
right what this means is this is
actually the genius the matter this way
of measuring angles this radians idea
right even though I catch it in the
terms of oh we need a new computer guys
degrees aren't good enough when you need
a new like simple diplomatic radians are
in fact not in unit at all do you see
that like they are a ratio between two
numbers I can say okay two to one that's
a ratio it doesn't have units on it it's
not about centimeters all whiteboard
markers
don't know whatever it is right two to
one is a ratio that is the same no
matter what you two looking there it is
in fact a unitless way of measuring
things so that is why from now on I'm
actually going to stop writing high
ratings like CQ whenever I apply on two
and PI and two pi you're like oh why
didn't you put the symbol there there is
a symbol by the way it looks like this
it's kind of like a seeds actually knock
can you see why it's wrong but no one
ever use it probably cuz it looks like a
C and because you really hate you it's
not a unit radians are in fact the
absence of units there are ratio now
we're comparing this link and battling
so I've developed I developed this guy
here this is the this is the phone
enough of arc length yeah the proper
weari country was this guy right it is
thank you
this is about a sector area right sector
area how did we go about calculating the
size of this if we were talking in
radians so I'm gonna start with this
what is the what is the full area of
this second class web right
- man that's the pool area now I know
that the angle attached to the entire
circle is 2 pi do you agree with that -
pi is that full revolution ok to play is
an MA if the area formula is it right
except it is it's kind of hiding there
right let me try and make it a little
more obvious and if you think back to
all the work you've been doing on
integration we do this kind of thing all
the time you're like I don't have to buy
their their problem I'll just stick a
half out the front and there's my 2 pi
is that okay you've seen that 2 pi is
there so if I didn't want to PI if I
wanted a different angle right like a
different proportion of the circle how I
did it what if I wanted just like a half
of the circles that have been tightening
what angle would I substitute in here
and the answer is out instead of 2 pi
which takes me all the way around I'm in
substitute in PI which is just half way
around right so I would say the area of
same sample is equal to 1/2 times
whatever that angle is pi times R square
right which of course is PI R square
which you've knew already right but now
I can pick any angle I like I don't just
have to point to PI or PI I can put the
end well
what happens if I put in 1 and we look
at that before what would the area of
that that's kind of it right that area B
I'll call that area it's going to be 1/2
times what's the angle it's 1
ah sweat it's half a speck whatever that
looks like be good now can generalize
this right just like this is generalized
this is the path length if I want a
different angle like is that a 1 or PI
or 2 pi in that spot there in the
brackets all I do is I supply the in and
that won't give me the area of a sector
the area of a sector and we just write
it in a slightly rearrange the way just
so it sounds nicer is 1/2 squared times
whatever angle is 1 right whether it's 2
pi or PI or 1 or 1/4 or whatever you
like
top us 15 you just kind of